PUBLIC IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS.
YOU REALLY CAN'T MAKE THIS STUFF
UP.
HERE WITH REACTION, THE AUTHOR
OF AND WE JUST FOUND OUT
TONIGHT, DEBUTING AS THE NUMBER
ONE "NEW YORK TIMES" BEST SELLE
BEST SELLER, "TRIGGERED HOW THE
LEFT PRIDES ON HATE" THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION DONALD TRUMP JR.
ALL RIGHT, SO YOUR DAD ONE
BEST SELLER -- SELL OR COME
ANYONE ELSE IN THE FAMILY WITH
NUMBER ONE BESTSELLERS?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
MY DAD PROBABLY HAD A COUPLE SO
I HAVE TO RIGHT A FEW MORE TO
CATCH UP.
I'M PRETTY HAPPY WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW, THANK YOU.
>> Sean: BEFORE WE GET TO THE
MADNESS YOU HAVE EXPERIENCED ON
THE ROAD WHICH IS HIGHLY
ENTERTAINING TO WATCH FROM A
DISTANCE AND I MEAN THAT FROM A
DISTANCE.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION TO
EVERYTHING TODAY?
I THOUGHT IT WAS A SCHIFF SHOW.
>> IT REALLY WAS.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING MORE
RIDICULOUS.
YOU CAN SEE EXACTLY WHAT AMERICA
VOTED AGAINST IN 2016.
CAREER, GOVERNMENT, BUREAUCRATS
DOING THEIR THING.
THERE IS NO FACT BASE.
EVERYTHING WAS HEARSAY.
I HEARD IT FROM A FRIEND WHO
HEARD IT FROM A FRIEND WHO HEARD
IT FROM A FRIEND.
THIS IS A JOKE.
THIS IS THEIR LEAD, SEAN?
AND THEN I HEARD THE DEMOCRATS
AND I HEARD HOW BAD OR
NONEXISTENT THEY WERE CASES.
WELL, HEARSAY IS OFTENTIMES MUCH
BETTER THAN REGULAR EVIDENCE.
I'M SAYING TO THAT GUY SAY THAT
WITH A STRAIGHT FACE IN THE
HALLS OF CONGRESS?
HEARSAY?
YOU MEAN LIKE THE TELEPHONE GAME
WE LEARNED ABOUT IN KINDERGARTEN
IS BETTER THAN ACTUAL DIRECT
EVIDENCE?
IT IS BETTER TO HEARD IT FROM A
FRIEND WHO HEARD IT FROM A
FRIEND THAN TO HAVE HEARD IT
WITH YOUR OWN EARS?
THAT IS THE LEVEL OF INSANITY
YOU SEE FROM THESE BUREAUCRATS
WHO HAVE TAKEN ANTI-TRUMP
POSITION THEY ARE BEING LED,
BADGERED, BULLIED BY SCHIFF TO
GET THEM WHAT THEY WANT BECAUSE
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA WILL CARRY
THEIR WATER AND FUNCTION AS A
MARKETING WING OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY WILL SAY WHATEVER IT IS
JUST TO GET OUT OF THERE.
WENT TO REPUBLICANS QUESTIONING,
ADAM SCHIFF CHANGES THE RULES,
CHANGES THE GOALPOST AND
PRETENDS THEY CANNOT ASK THAT
QUESTION ANYMORE.
IT IS NEVER-ENDING.
I MEAN, IT IS A COMEDY AT THIS
POINT.
IT IS SO RIDICULOUS.
IT IS EXACTLY WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE NEEDED TO SEE.
IF YOU DID NOT BUY AT THE FIRST
TIME COME IF YOU DIDN'T BUY IT
THE SECOND TIME WITH ALL THE
HOAXES, RUSSIAN VERSION ONE,
TWO, AND THE COLLUSION ON SINCE
WE HEARD THE GOSPEL, FACT FOR
THREE YEARS.
YOU WILL BELIEVE AT THIS TIME,
SEAN BECAUSE THIS TIME IT'S
DIFFERENT.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
IT IS INSANITY.
>> Sean: SO YOU GET TO THE
RE-VISUALS TODAY, THE PRESIDENT
OR TO WANT TO TURKEY COME UP
VERY IMPORTANT STUFF WITH YOUR
DAD.
THAT IS HAPPENING AT THE SAME
TIME FOR THE SCHIFF SHOW IS
GOING ON AND I'M THINKING, YOU
HAVE THE PRESIDENT RECORD ON THE
DASH UNEMPLOYMENT SINCE 1969 AND
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC.
AND THEN I THINK OKAY, NAME ONE
THING DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE.
>> YOU CAN'T.
>> Sean: TO BE MORE SAFE AND
SECURE, CREATE JOBS AND BE MORE
PROSPEROUS?
I CANNOT THINK OF ONE THING, NOT
ONE PERSON WATCHING, NOT ONE
PERSON WATCHING CAN NAME ONE
THING THAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
DONE IN THE YEAR THAT THEY HAVE
HAD THE HOUSE.
NOT WANTING TO MAKE A SAFER, NOT
ONE THING TO MOVE US FORWARD.
THE USMCA, SEAN, THE REEK
NEGOTIATION OF NAFTA, THE THING
THAT EVERYONE SAID WOULD NEVER B
THAT EVERYONE SAID WOULD NEVER E
ABLE TO RENEGOTIATE IS, MY
FATHER DID IT.
HE GOT IT DONE BECAUSE HE IS A
NEGOTIATOR UNLIKE ALL OF THESE
CLOWNS IN CONGRESS WHO ARE JUST
BUREAUCRATS.
HE RENEGOTIATED WITH CANADA,
MEXICO.
THEY ARE IN AGREEMENT AND IT HAS
BEEN SITTING ON NANCY PELOSI'S
DESK FOR NINE MONTHS.
IT WOULD CREATE 900,000 JOBS FOR
AMERICAN.
BRING THE JOBS AND THE DREAMS
THAT WE HAVE DONE NOTHING BUT
EXPORT, BRING THAT BACK SO
AMERICANS CAN LIVE IT.
IT WOULD ALSO GIVE TRUMP A WIN
LET'S NOT VOTE ON IT.
YOU KNOW IT WOULD PASS WITH
FLYING COLORS WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
SHE WON'T BRING IT UP BECAUSE
SHE WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
TRUMP DOESN'T GET ANY ADDITIONAL
CREDIT DESPITE ALL OF THE THINGS
HE'S DONE FOR AMERICA.
THAT IS THE LEVEL OF HATRED YOU
SEE FROM THE LEFT.
THEY ARE NOT LOOKING TO GOVERN.
THEY ARE NOT LOOKING TO DO
ANYTHING.
THEY ARE LOOKING TO TRY TO
RESIST BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY
CAN'T BEAT TRUMP IN THE POLLS.
THEY WILL TRY TO IMPEACH.
IT WILL NOT WORK IN THE LONG RUN
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE
THROUGH IT, SEAN, THEY ARE SICK
OF THIS GARBAGE.
>> Sean: QUICK LAST TEN
SECONDS DID YOUR DAD HEAR ABOUT
YOU BEING NUMBER ONE, DEBUTING
ON "THE NEW YORK TIMES" LIST?
>> HE DID AND HE WAS AS
SURPRISED AS I WAS BECAUSE HE
HEARD ABOUT CONSERVATIVE WRITERS
GETTING BLOCKED FROM A BAND OR
BEING THERE SO I WILL GIVE THEM